ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะคุณเหลี่ยมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่า
วันนี้วันอะไรคะพี่เรียมเอาวันหรือ
วันอาทิตย์ค่ะเอ๋
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์นะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 29 ค่ะวันที่ 29 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะมีผช
2565 ค่ะแล้วปีคศอะไรคะมีข้อศ.
2522 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลาออกกี่โมงคะตอนนี้ติด
22.39 ก็คือนาย
เที่ยงที่ 12:39 นาทีนะคะเป็นคลิปที่สาม
ของวันอาทิตย์เนาะที่ครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋ทำ
ด้วยกันนะคะให้ค่ะเพราะว่า
ไม่จบ
ไปตกแล้วเก็บที่แล้วผู้พูดถึงวัดหลวงพ่อ
โสธรนะคะเสร็จแล้วครูเรียนว่าสนใจเกิด
อะไรขึ้นทำไม
ทำไมไหว้ขอแล้วได้ใช่ไหมคะ
ก็เลยคิดอยู่เตรียมส่งมาอีกจะเล่าอะไรต่อ
แต่ว่าครั้งที่แล้วเวลาหมดก่อนเดี๋ยวค่อย
เอาอยากเลยเนี่ยกูแล้วก็คิดว่านักเรียน
อยากรู้
ถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเราไปดูกันเลยค่ะเดี๋ยวไม่
จบจ้าเกิดอะไรขึ้นคะครูเอ๋
จีอย่างนี้เราต้องมาที่ตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะนัก
เรียนพื้นเราก็มาดูว่าสำหรับนักเรียนที่
ดูคลิปนี้อ่ะยังไม่ได้ฟังคลิปที่แล้วนะคะ
ก็ต้องบอกนักเรียนก่อนว่าครูเรียมกับครู
เอ๋และคุยการถึงวัดวัดนี้
วัดหลวงพ่อโสธรหรือวัดโสธรนะคะซึ่งคนไทย
ในภาคตะวันออกหรืออาจจะที่อื่นเนี่ยเรา
บอกว่านับถือคือไหว้เราก็มากๆ
จะวัดเล็กๆก็ใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้นนะ
คะที่บอกว่าสั่งสิทธิ์มากๆบางคนอยากมีลูก
ก็ไปแล้วก็ไหว้แล้วก็ขอรูปบางคนอยากก็
อยากให้ธุรกิจดีๆทำงานแล้วก็ดีดีๆก็ไป
ไหว้แล้วก็ขอโชคดีนะคะถ้าเกิดขอขอเราได้
แล้วเขาทำยังไงกันนะคะตัวเองเราต้องมีของ
ไปให้ทุกเวลาขอเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าบนขอก็คือ
ต้องบอกว่าเออถ้าได้แล้วจะให้อะไรแต่เขา
บอกว่าหลวงพ่อก็จะชอบไข่ต้มดอกไม้นี่อัน
นี้ค่ะ
นะลูกไข่ต้มหยิบพวงมาลัยมีดอกไม้แล้วก็มี
ละครนะคะรำ
รำละคร
3 อย่างแต่วิวิธีวายนะคะวิธีไหว้ขอก็คือ
ธูป 3 ดอกเราก็บอกชื่อตัวเองอ่าไม่ใช่พูด
อ้อหลวงพ่ออยากได้แต่ไม่จะซื้อตัวเองหลวง
พ่อก็ไม่รู้ใครขอ
ผู้เรียนก็ต้องบอกเอ่อชื่อเรียมค่ะค่ะนาม
สกุลอะไรอายุเท่าไหร่บ้านอยู่ที่ไหน
แล้วก็ตั้งใจขอถ้าได้เรียมจะเอาไข่ไข่ต้ม
อ้าวๆเอาดอกไม้มาไหว้อย่างเงี้ยค่ะ God
เป็นพูดถึงความศักดิ์สิทธิ์นะคะที่นี้เรา
ก็สงสัยกันว่า
ศักดิ์สิทธิ์ของจะศักดิ์สิทธิ์จริงเพราะ
คนไปไหว้เยอะมากนักแต่หลวงพ่อโสธรเนี่ยมา
จากไหน
คลิปนี้ค่ะคลิปนี้ครูเอกกับครูเรียมก็จะ
มาเล่าถึงประวัตินะประวัติคือหลวงพ่อโสธร
เนี่ยมาจากไหนนะคะเขาบอกว่าอย่างนี้ค่ะ
ครูเรียมคะอ่ะเหรียญหลวงพ่อโสธรเนี่ยลอย
น้ำมา
Facebook ที่แล้วหรือเปล่าคะแล้วก็ว่าย
น้ำมาแบบนี้หรือเปล่าไม่ใช่เป็นเป็นพระ
พุทธรูป
พระพุทธรูปแต่ที่นี้เนี่ยคลิปที่แล้วครู
เอกขอโทษกูเองบอกเป็นพ่อคิดว่าพระพุทธรูป
องค์เล็กๆแต่แต่จริงๆไม่ใช่องค์เล็กองค์
ใหญ่ค่ะทุเรียนม
หัวฟังอันนี้ฟังอันนี้อ่าอันนี้แล้วก็งง
ฮ่าๆเอาฉบับนี้แล้วกันแล้วก็
อันมีอะไรที่เล่าเล่าเล่ากันมาน่ะเพราะ
เราก็เล่ากันพูดบอกแล้วบอกเล่าต่อๆกันมา
บางทีก็ฟังแล้วก็คนนี้บอกอันนี้คนที่บอก
อันนี้คือเขาบอกว่าสมัครและก็เนี้ยคือมี 3
ความเชื่อนะคะอ่าที่บอกว่าหนึ่งเป็นพระ
พุทธรูปทองแบบนี้เลย
องค์หนูประมาณเมตรกว่าๆแล้วก็ขว้างก็เมตร
กว่าๆกัน
สองนะคะที่ 2 บอกว่าเป็นพระพุทธรูปเป็น
ไม้
แกะสลักจากไม้ก็เลยลอยน้ำมาได้นะคะอ่ะอ่า
แต่ความเชื่อหนึ่งก็เชื่อต่างอ่าเป็นพระ
พุทธรูปที่เป็นทองแต่มีปูนโอเนี่ย
8888 ซีเมนต์ปูนซีเมนต์ 8 ชายใช่แล้วก็
ลอยมากับแม่น้ำนะคะอ่ะรอยมากับแม่น้ำอา
บางคนก็บอกว่า
ลักษณะของพระพุทธรูปน่าจะแต่ของทางหนึ่งณ
สถานเชียงใหม่ลอยมาจากเชียงใหม่
อ่านแต่ว่าบางตำนานก็บอกว่าน่าจะจะอยุธยา
คือเอาจริงๆอีกอันนึงบอกว่าทำจากหินทราย
ไม่ใช่ทองไม่ใช่ไม้ถ้วยตอนหินเรียบครูเอก
กับเรียมที่ได้ยินมานะได้ตามมาน่ะไม่
เหมือนกันเลยนะไม่เหมือนกันหมดหลายอย่าง
มากๆคือคือเอาง่ายๆว่าเอาจริงๆเรียนกับ
ครูเอกก็ไม่เคยเห็นหลวงพ่อโสธรองค์จริง
ชั้นอาโอวีองค์จริงเนี่ยเราจะไม่เห็นเขา
จะเก็บเอาไว้เพิ่งได้เจอสวยมากรู้ว่าจะมี
คนมันมาขโมยไปหน้าบ้านเราก็จะเป็นเห็น
เป็นองค์จำลองแบบนี้เราเรียกว่าองค์จำลอง
งั้นแนะตำนานก็จะบอกบอกเราก็เลยตกมาแล้ว
จริงคืออะไรนะคะก็ไม่รู้แล้วก็ไม่เป็นไร
ไม่เป็นไรเราฟังตำนานแล้วกันทำไมต้องเก็บ
องค์จริงตามตำนานนะเขาบอกว่าอย่างนี้ครู
เรียมเขาบอกว่ามีพระพุทธรูป 3 องค์เอาอัน
นี้แล้วกันนะคะ 3 องค์เนี่ยลอยน้ำมา
แม่น้ำมันกับแม่นางเหรอ
ใช่มากับแม่น้ำเรียงกันมาเลยก็มีองค์
หนึ่งองค์ 2 องค์ 3 หลวงพ่อโสธรที่เราจำ
ลังจะเล่านะคือองค์ที่สองรอยมาด้วยกันนะ
คะมากันที่แม่น้ำบางปะกงเนี่ยนะค่ะ
แม่น้ำอันนี้ชื่อแม่น้ำบางประกงนะคะบาง
ประกงก็เป็นแม่น้ำที่ยาวนะแล้วก็ใหญ่ๆ
ก็ตอนและตอนแรกเนี่ยไม่ใช่บริเวณนี้นะคะ
ครูเรียมพระพุทธรูปทางมี 3 องค์
ไปเจอที่ไหนคะไปขึ้นบริเวณนึงนะคะบริเวณ
หนึ่งอ่าคู๋จำชื่อไม่ได้ว่าเขาเรียกว่า
อะไรในตอนนั้นที่หมู่บ้านหนึ่งแล้วก็คน
น่ะเขาก็เห็นเขาก็มีเชือกนะคะเชื่อไอ้ไม่
รู้เชือกมาป่ะ
ไม่รู้เสื้อให้นะคะเปลี่ยน
หาลูกเชือกให้นะคะ
เสื้อ
ก็คือเห็นพระร้อยน้ำนั้นแหละ
ใช่ๆพระลอยน้ำมานะคะเราก็เขาก็ไปเอาเชือก
นี้ละกันเพื่อ
คุยกับรูปมาใส่ตอนนี้เลยนะคะนั้น
เขาก็ไปเอาเชือกนะค่ะครูเรียมจะเอาชื่อ
เชื่อก็เชื่อกันเค้าเอ๋
เอามาผูกที่องค์พระ
ไอ้ภู
ผู้ที่องค์พระแล้วก็ดึง
ดึงไปไหนคะดึงขึ้นนะจะอาจจะเอาจะเอาพระนะ
ขึ้นมาไว้ที่หมู่บ้านนี้นะคะ
แต่ว่าไม่ขึ้นค่ะ
อาร์มไม่ขึ้นน่ะทุเรียนหนักมากหนักแล้วก็
ไม่ขึ้นแล้วก็ปรากฏว่าเกิดเหมือนกับมีลม
มีมีมีลมมีฝนมีฝนตกมีลมมีอะไรแม่ใช่แม่
น้ำแถวเนี้ยก็เกิดปั่นป่วน
เกิดอะไรไม่รู้แล้วพระ
แต่ถ้าดูจากตรงนี้นะคะอันนี้ลอยน้ำมาใช่
ไหมคะอ่ะ
ลายน้ำมาตามน้ำเข้าคู๋ให้ไปดูน้ำตรงนี้
ก่อน
น้ำจะไหลไปทางนี้นะคะโคเรียมไหลไปทางนิ
ไปไปทางนี้แล้วก็ออกไปก็ตรงนี้ก็จะเป็น
ทะเล
ทะเลทะเล
อันนี้คือ
คณิตวัดภาโสธรแต่ว่าแต่ว่าในเรื่องที่เขา
เล่ากันเนี่ยเขาบอกว่าตรงนี้ค่ะองค์พระ
อรอยมาตามน้ำรอยลอยมาตามน้ำเพราะเอาเชื่อ
ไปผูกปั๊บเกิดปั่นป่วนเชือกขาดกูเชื่อ
แล้วก็
ขาดเลยค่ะชื่อน่ะขาด
น่าเชื่อกับพื้นอ่ะโอ๊ยขาด
แล้วก็องค์พระก็รอยเหมือนลอยทวนน้ำ
น้ำแน่นไหลไปทางนี้พระต้องรอยลงไปใช่ไหม
คะตอนแรกลอยลงมาแต่คนผูกปั๊บพักก็เลยรอย
ทวนน้ำขึ้นไป
งอกก็พระลอยทวนน้ำขึ้นไปทั้งสามองค์ตกใจ
ไหมตอบใจให้คนตกใจนะคะเสร็จแล้วพระก็จม
น้ำแล้วก็หายไป
อ้าวแล้วเรื่องนี้ก็จบแล้วหายไปยังไม่จบ
ค่ะ
ยังไม่จบอ้าวบริเวณนั้นน่ะค่ะบริเวณที่
แรกที่เห็นเห็นพระทั้ง 3 รูปเนี่ยค่ะทั้ง
สามองค์นะคะก็เขาก็เรียกว่าสามพระทวน
สาธุส่วนก็คือก็มีน้ำไหลมาที่นี่แต่พระ
แน่นลอยขึ้นก็เรียกว่าทวนน้ำสามพระทวนน้ำ
ก็คือพระ 3 องค์รอยทวนน้ำ
นั้น
R
ผสมหมดแล้วกันเอาใหม่สมมติว่าน้ำไหล่ตรง
นี้น้ำไหลไปทางนี้พระลอยขึ้นมาถ่ายเนี้ย
ก็เรียกว่าทวนน้ำเพราะว่าควรลากขึ้นลาก
ขึ้นเกิดลมเกิดพายุเกิดคลื่นเกิดคลื่นอ่ะ
คืนเครื่องเสร็จพระก็ไหลทวนลอยทวนน้ำขึ้น
ไป
บริเวณนี้ก็เลยเรียกว่าสามพระทวนแต่ว่าพอ
นานๆพูดเช่นเปลี่ยนชื่อเป็นอะไรสัมปทวน
สัมปทวน
ได้ R ที่จังหวัดฉะเชิงเทรา
หมอเขาจะมี
บริเวณนึงเรียกว่าสัมปทวนมาจากคำว่าสาม
พระลอยทวนน้ำอ๋อวันนี้เองเราก็เอกเล่าถึง
คอลอยทวนน้ำมาแล้วพักก็จมลงไปแล้วก็หายไป
แล้วก็ไปไปโทรแต่ละวัดไม่เหมือนกันแต่ว่า
มีอยู่วัดนึงค่ะครูเรียมวัดนี้วัดเมตรวัด
วัดนี้ล่ะค่ะวัดที่เราวัดที่เราเรียนกัน
เนี่ยค่ะ
วันนี้นี่
วัดหลวงพ่อโสธรเนี่ยค่ะเมื่อก่อนเป็นวัด
เล็กๆนะคะวัดเล็กๆที่บริเวณหน้าวัดนะคะ
หน้าวัดเนี่ยเขาจะมีเสาแบบนี้นะเสาอันนี้
เราเรียกว่าเสาหงส์
เสาหงส์ทั้งหมดนี้เป็นรูปอะไรคะโดนสัตว์
ผงถ่านตัวนี้ค่ะคงและก็
เสาหงส์ก็เรียกว่า
วัด
เสาหงส์เมื่อก่อน
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยปรากฏว่าไม่รู้เกิดอะไร
ขึ้นเสาหักค่ะหาค่ะเสร็จเนี่ยเขาก็เลย
เปลี่ยนเป็นชื่อวัดเสาทอนเอาอ๊อด
พรแปลว่าตัดลงมานะตัดลงบางงาแล้วพอหงส์
หักปุ๊บเขาก็เปลี่ยนเป็นธงแทน
มีธงไม่รู้ธงอะไรกูเองไม่แน่ใจเป็นธงนะคะ
ก็เป็นก็เปลี่ยนเป็นโทนะคะจากชื่อวัด
เสาหงส์ก็เป็นเสาทอนนะคะตอนหลังเนี่ยก็
เปลี่ยนมาเปลี่ยนเป็นอาทรณ์
เสาทอนก็เป็นโสธร
แล้วก็ปัจจุบันก็มีเสาหงส์ใหม่ค่ะเนี้ย
ค่ะ
เสาหงส์ใหม่ก็ถามว่าเองวัดเนี้ยวัดของคน
ไทยใครสร้างวัดก็ไม่รู้เพราะว่าเสาหงส์
อันนี้เขาบอกเป็นเหมือนของคนมอญ
แล้วก็ที่
ที่สมุทรปราการเองจะมีคนมอญเยอะๆคนมอญก็
จะเดินทางมาที่
แถวๆวัดหลวงพ่อโสธรแล้วก็มาทำงานจะพาย
เรือไปก็ไปทำงานแล้วก็กลับอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
นะคะคือจะพายเรือไปตามคลองนะคะไม่ใช่ปลา
แม่น้ำก็มีความเชื่อในๆเรื่องเอามาเกี่ยว
กันนะคะก็อันนี้เอาเอาแค่ชื่อก่อนว่าทำไม
วัดชื่อโสธรนะคะแล้วก็แต่ปรากฏว่าพระทั้ง
สามองค์นะคะครูเรียมทั้ง 3 รูปเนี่ยนะคะ
สาวรูปแล้วก็จมไปแล้วแต่มีรูปนึงก็คือนี่
ล่ะค่ะหลวงพ่อโสธรเนี่ยค่ะมาลอยขึ้นที่
หน้าวัด
หน้าใหม่
วัดโสธรนะคะว่า
วัดเสาธงตอนนั้นใช่ไหมคะเมื่อก่อนเป็นวัด
ของเขื่อนวัดเสาธรวัดเสาธร
รณ์วัดวัดเสาธงการก็มาลอยที่นี่เค้าก็จะ
ลอยองค์เดียว
เหลือองค์เดียวองค์เดียวนะคะเอาเชือกไป
มัดเองไหมคะ
ให้ก็เหมือนเดิมเหมือนเดิมคนที่นี่ก็เอา
เชือกสอดก็เอาเชือกมา
เอก Copy กัน
ก็เอาเชือกมานะคะ
เอาเชือกมาแล้วก็
เชื่องเนี่ย
คู๋ทำตอนนี้เลยนะคะนักเรียนเอาเชือกเนี่ย
อื้อคือ
เอาเชือกมาแล้วก็มาเอาชื่ออันนี้ค่ะมามัด
องค์พระนะคะอา
เอาเชือกมาแล้วก็มัดเฮ้ยขอโทษคะนักเรียน
ขา
มาเชือกมาแล้วก็
มัดองค์พระ Double ดึงหนึ่งขึ้นจากน้ำ
มีคนเยอะมากที่จะดึงองค์พระขึ้นจากน้ำ
ปรากฏว่าดึงไม่ดีขึ้นเหมือนกันค่ะครู
เรียม
เกิดอะไรหรือเฟสทำไมจะดึงไม่ขึ้นเขาบอก
ว่าหนักมากหนักแล้วก็ดึงไม่ขึ้น
จนมีคนนึงจนต้องไปเทิร์นได้ก็ไปเชิญไปหา
หาว่าใครนะเก่งนะคะเออครูเอกก็ไม่รู้ว่า
เป็นพระหรือว่าเป็นคนธรรมดาแต่เขาเรียก
กันว่าอาจารย์
ถ้าอาจารย์ก็คือเองความรู้เรียนเกี่ยวกับ
ศาสนาพุทธนะคะเราก็สวดมนต์เก่งๆสามีมีคำ
พูดพูดในสัตว์แล้วก็ได้เลยนะคาถาคาถา
เรียกว่า
พิมลเนี่ยเก่งๆก็ไปเชิญมานะคะคนเนี้ยเขา
ก็เลยมาเดี๋ยวนะคุยมีรูปไหมอ่ะอันนี้ไม่
ใช่ไม่ใช่ของที่วัดโสธรนะคะเขาก็จะตั้ง
แบบนี้ค่ะเรียกว่าสารว่าเป็นปลา
ศาลเพียงตาอันนี้เป็นคนละที่นะคะศาลเพียง
ตาแล้วก็อ้ะทำศาลเพียงตาแล้วก็เชิญเทวดา
[เพลง]
เชิญเทวดาไทยนะที่กูอีกว่าได้เป็นเทวดา
ของต่างชาติเชิญเทวดาไทยน่ะมาอยู่ที่
ศาลพี่ Turn มาเยอะๆแล้วเขาก็
อ่ะเอาสายสิญจน์ค่ะคะเรียงแบบเนี้ย
เล็กๆใช้สิทธิ์นี้ใหญ่หรือเล็กครับ
ทุเรียน i4 นี่เล็กค่ะ
โรงเรียนมองเห็นไหมคุยขยาย
สายสิญจน์นะค่ะลงไปในน้ำนะคะลงไปในน้ำแบบ
นี้มิลงไปในน้ำที่มีหลวงพ่อโสธรเนี่ยค่ะ
ถ้าเอาสายสิญจน์และไป
ไปรัดชัชใช่ไหมคะที่ตัวหลวงพ่อ
นะค่ะสายสิญจน์มันเล็กมากเลยนะคะพี่เอ๋
เชื่อแบบตลกกว่าสายสิญจน์นะ
ขึ้นมาไม่ได้เลย
ก็อันนิสัยสิทธิ์เล็กๆสะอาดแล้วเขาก็สวด
มนต์แล้วก็เราเรียกว่าอัญเชิญนะคะ
เชิญพระเนี่ยก็พุทธรูปองค์เนื้อค่ะให้
ขึ้นมาอยู่ที่วัดวัดนี้วัดประหาเอาทอนใช่
เขาทอดเวลาที่เราอาจเชิญพระขึ้นมาอยู่น่ะ
เราไม่บอกว่าพระขอเชิญให้อยู่ที่วัดไม่
ได้พูดแบบนี้นะคะพูดว่าขอเชิญพระ
ประดิษฐาน
ประดิษฐ์สะพานก็คืออยู่ที่อยู่ที่วัดนี้
คุณเรียมเชื่อมั้ยปรากฎว่าเป็นยังไงคะ
เกิดอะไรขึ้น
พระขึ้นมาได้ค่ะ
30 เล็กๆ
เฮ้ยสายสิญจน์เล็กๆเนี่ยดึงพระขึ้นมาได้
ง่ายๆ
ง่ายๆด้วย
แต่เชือกใหญ่ๆน่ะ
ดึงพระขึ้นมาไม่ได้ขาด
แต่สายสิญจน์เล็กๆเนี่ยค่ะถ้าไม่ใช่พระ
อาจารย์คนนั้นน่ะก็สามารถเชิญน่ารักเชิญ
พระพุทธรูปองค์เนี้ยขึ้นมาอยู่ที่วัดนี้
วัดโสธรเนี่ยได้นะคะก็เลยชื่อหลวงพ่อโสธร
นะคะเป็นพระ
เป็นพระอะพระพุทธรูปแม่พี่เอกตายนักเรียน
ดูพระพุทธรูปอันนี้ไม่ว่าป่าปางสมาธินั่ง
ทรงนี้แหละราคาดังนั้นเนี่ยกูเรียมทุกๆปี
นะคะทุกปีเขาก็จะมีแบบนี้ค่ะมีมีเป็น
ประเพณีที่จะมีพระพุทธรูปหน่อยน้ำแล้วก็
มีสายสิญจน์แล้วก็เฉลิมขึ้นมาเชิญที่มาขอ
ทำเหมือนที่อัญเชิญ
พระหลวงพ่อโสธรขึ้นมาครั้งแรก
High ค่ะชายเนื่องจาก
บอกว่าทุกปีปีครูเอกก็ไม่เคยไปดูนะคะแต่
เขาบอกว่าทุกปีจะทำแบบนี้และคนก็นับถือ
แล้วก็เชื่อมากไปขอกับหลวงพ่อโสธรองค์
จริงน่ะเราไม่ได้เห็นนะคะเราไม่ได้เห็น
ห้างต้องหรอกนะก็
ต้องบอกนักเรียนมากเรียกค่ะถ้าเราไปที่
วัดจะเห็นแบบนี้นะคะละเอกก็คิดว่าองค์
จริงเพราะว่าได้ยินคนแก่แกบอกว่าอมจริง
อยู่ข้างในข้างในไหนข้างในองค์นี้เฮ้ย
โอเค
เราก็ไม่รู้ว่าองค์จริงเป็นเป็นไม้เป็น
ทองเป็นหินก็ไม่รู้จริงไม่รู้แต่แต่
ปัจจุบันเนี่ยมีข้อมูลบอกว่าองค์จริงเก็บ
อยู่ข้างในที่ทุกคนมองไม่เห็นค่ะ
ตรงนี้ก็เป็นเป็นองค์จำลองทั้งหมดเป็น
องค์จำลอง
เป็นองค์จำลองคลองหลวงพ่อโสธรองค์จริงก็
เก็บรักษาเอาไว้ที่จะมีทัพพระผู้ใหญ่ที่
จะเห็น
นี้นะค่ะก็คือเป็นความเชื่อว่าสิ่งที่
เล่าต่อๆกันมาเน๊าะคนอะไรคนก็เลยเชื่อใน
ความศักดิ์สิทธิ์ของหลวงพ่อโสธรมากๆเพราะ
ว่าเชือกเส้นใหญ่ๆนะดึงขึ้นมาก็ไม่ได้แต่
ใช้สายสีแล้วก็สวดมนต์เอาขึ้นมาโมโหเชือก
ขึ้นมาไม่ได้สายสิญจน์สายสิญจน์ดึงขึ้นมา
ได้
เราก็เลยเชื่อเรื่องความศักดิ์สิทธิ์นะคะ
เราก็มีคนไปไหว้แล้วก็ขอลาเพราะขอแล้วได้
ก็บอกต่อๆกันไปว่าถ้ามีปัญหาก็ไปขอหลวง
พ่อโสธรหลวงพ่อโสธรก็จะให้ทุกคนละไม่สบาย
ก็ขอให้แข็งแรงก็สบายใจไปหาหมอแล้วก็แข็ง
แรงด้วยนะคะอ่ะคะหรือว่าอยากมีลูกก็ขอ
แล้วได้ลูก
อยากมีงานทำก็ขอแล้วก็มีงานทำกูขอละอย่าง
นะไม่พูดเล่นๆนะทุเรียนมต้องขอจริงๆนะคะ
ไม่อวยขออันนี้ได้ไหมค่ะไม่ได้ต้องรู้สึก
ศรัทธาแล้วก็เข้ารบจริงๆราคาร้อนเธอก็ขอ
เอกยังไม่เคยขอถ้าเกิดอยากไปละลองดูซิมา
เสือได้หรือเปล่าเราไม่ได้ไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
หรืออาจจะได้แต่ถ้าได้แล้วคุณเรียมไม่ไป
เอาไข่ไปไหว้คุณเรียมลืมอันนี้ก็ไม่ดีนะ
คะไม่ดีเหรอคือคืนเขาบอกว่าต้องสัตว์ผ่าน
จริงๆขอได้คุณต้องกลับไปแล้วก็มีไหว้ไข่
ไหว้ด้วยหลับด้วยแก้บนนะคะแก้บนด้วยรำแก้
บนด้วยไข่ดอกไม้เช้าที่แล้วที่เราคุย
เตือนฉันที่แล้วที่เราคุยกันพูดเอ๋บอกว่า
ไหว้เราก็ขอที่บ้านน่ะได้ตั้งแต่ว่าเวลา
ที่แก้บนน่ะคะ Oppo บนมันไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ง่วงต้องไปแก้บนที่วัดที่อยู่จังหวัด
จังหวัดฉะเชิงเทรา
มีโคเรียมต้องต้องคิดดีๆนะคะก่อนจะบ่น
ก่อนจะหม่นเพราะขับรถลายมากเออแล้วแต่ครู
เรียมขอใหญ่ๆด้วยขอเล็กๆคุณแม่กูเอ๋ก็แก้
บนที่บ้านอ้าวแม้ว่าขอเล็กๆเล็กๆนะเล็กๆ
เล็กๆ
เท่าไหร่
ไม่รู้จำไม่ได้แต่ว่าแต่ว่าคุณแม่ก็คิด
ว่าต้องไปที่วัดสัก 1 ครั้งไปที่วัดดีขอ
ลาก็สุดท้ายก็ไปที่วัดนะคะที่สมมติว่าขอ
ถ้าไม่สบายโอขอให้แข็งแรงอ่ะแล้วก็แก้วบน
ครั้งแรกที่บ้านก่อนแล้วก็พอมีเวลาก็ไป
ที่วัดใช่แม่กูเองจะได้สบายใจ
ใช่เขาก็จะแก้แบบนี้งั้นถ้ากูเรียนจะขอกู
เรียนก็ต้องคิดขออะไรถ้ากูเรียนบอกว่า
ขอให้
1 เดือน 1 เดือนนี้มีคนกด Subscribe
1,000 คนนี้
1,000 คนเรียบประเทศไปพูดถวายค่ะบทที่
วัด
ลองไหมคะทุเรียนมลอง
ดีไหมคะนักเรียนครูเรียนควรจะบนมั้ยถ้า
เกิดบนแล้วก็ได้ 1,000  Subscribe เบ้อนะ
ต้องบอกเวลาด้วยนะครูเรียนก็บอกระยะเวลา
ด้วยนะ
[เพลง]
จะมากูเรียนต้องขอแล้วบอกเวลาว่าเวลาเท่า
ไหร่ภายใน 1 เดือนภายใน 2 เดือนภายใน 1
ปีอย่างเงี้ยก็ต้องบอกเวลาไปด้วย
ถ้าเกิดว่าถ้าเกิดเห็นเตรียมไปวัดหลวงพ่อ
โสธรแสดงว่าเดิมก็บนไปแล้ว
หรือถ้าคู่เตรียมขอแล้วครูเรียนไม่ระบุ
เวลาใช่มั้ยไม่ระบุเวลาแล้วครูเรียมทำไม
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้อันนี้
ไม่ก็ไม่ได้จริงๆเพราะกูเรียนไม่บอกเวลา
คุณเรียนต้องบอกเวลาด้วย
แวะซื้อเหลี่ยมนะบ้านอยู่ที่นี่ขออันนี้
ช่วงเวลานี้ถึงเวลานิและขอได้ 1 อย่างนะ
คะไม่ใช่ข้อ 3 อย่างสี่อย่างห้าอย่างทุก
อย่างเลยได้ครั้งละ 1 อย่างพอได้เสร็จ
แล้วแก้บนเสร็จแล้วโอกาสถ้าอยากขอใหม่ก็
ค่อยขอ
โอเคจะได้นักเรียนจะได้ฟัง
ขอได้นักเรียนอาจจะไปลองขอดูว่าได้อุ้ม
เด็กนกขอขอให้ผมเรียนภาษาไทยเก่งๆ
ภายใน 1 ปี
ค่ะก็จะบอกว่าฟังทุกวัน
ถ้า 1 ปีฟัง 1 ครั้งไม่เก่งต้องฟังทุกวัน
นะคะก็จะเก่ง
อ้ะนักเรียนชาร์จเชื่อไม่เชื่อแล้วแต่
เนาะแล้วแต่คนนะคะใครเชื่อก็ไปไหว้อ่ะใคร
นับถือใครศรัทธาเชื่อนับถือศรัทธาก็ไป
ไหว้ใครไม่เชื่อก็ไม่เป็นไรนะคะเราไม่ว่า
กันนะคะอันนี้ให้ขับรถที่ดูไปถ่ายรูปเต็ม
ที่ๆนะคะแต่วันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนักเรียนก็
รู้จักประวัติหลวงพ่อโสธรแล้วนะคะเป็นวัด
ที่มีคนไทยจำนวนมากเหมือนกันที่ไปแล้วก็
ไหว้นับถือนะคะบางคนก็อาจจะนับถือวันอื่น
แต่ก็มีคนจำนวนมากๆเลยไปที่วัดนี้นะคะใช่
ไปสองค่ะและกูเองบนตัวเองไม่ชอบบนตัวเอง
ไม่ชอบขอตัวเองกลัวขอนะคะ
โอเคค่ะคลิปนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะได้ค่ะ
หมดเวลาแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอครูเอ๋กับครูเรียมใน
ช่องคอมที Head  Bow  Tie ในคลิปถัดไปนะ
คะถ้าวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะเอ๋บ๊าย
บายค่ะได้ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ
ม.ค